could you please offer advice for
individuals with high intelligence but
low extraversion and low agreeableness
and making and maintaining social
connections and friendships well I would
that's Roger Roger I would say make a
plan again spend some time on it weekly
go to things like meetups there's a site
called meetup calm that's a good place
to meet people do whatever you have to
to meet people take a course strike up a
conversation you know and and ask
questions and listen that that's
particularly good if you're low and
agreeableness people really like to be
listened to you know we don't want to
pester them with questions too badly but
you can get an awful long ways by
listening to people and asking them
questions so people hardly ever get
listened to and they're so damn help
happy when you do it that that that
they're likely to open themselves up to
you very very rapidly so get them
talking and when they say something you
don't quite catch or understand and ask
them about it and and that can help you
move forward but put some time into it
like you need to be going out at least
once a week and find some social places
that you can go to regularly that's
another thing you can do you know is
that pick a couple of hangouts like a
local bar or something like that or
whatever but go there regularly and say
hi to the people who own it and run it
and you know eventually you'll be a
regular and then you can start to meet
people by doing that but you know it
might take you two or three years to get
good at it
I've seen people go to go from being
afraid to strike up to have a
conversation with a friend in a in a
coffee shop you know like have a panic
attack thinking about that to actually
doing stand-up comedy so you can really
move yourself a long ways with you if
you make a
time plan